REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS IN THE
PAST.
>> Bret: FROM TEXAS, WE MOVE
FURTHER NORTH TO THE STATE OF
NORTH DAKOTA.
A DEMOCRATIC INCUMBENT ON THE
ROPES.
SENATOR HEIDI HEITKAMP SAYS A
STAFF MEMBER RESPONSIBLE FOR AN
INCREDIBLY EMBARRASSING MISTAKE
IS NO LONGER ON HER CAMPAIGN.
A NEWSPAPER AD FOR HEITKAMP
AIMED AT ATTACKING REPORTER
KEVIN KRAMER USE NAMES WITHOUT
THEIR PERMISSION SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> IF YOU OPEN A PAPER IN
NORTH DAKOTA THIS PAST SUNDAY,
YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN AN OPEN
LETTER TO REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
MEN AND SENATE HOPEFUL KEVIN
KRAMER.
A LETTER A POLITICAL AD PAID FOR
BY HIM INCUMBENT DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR HEIDI HEITKAMP TOLD
KRAMER SHE'S WRONG WRONG ABOUT
THE #MeToo MOVEMENT, IT'S NOT
A MOVEMENT TOWARDS
VICTIMIZATION.
OVER 100 PEOPLE SIGNED IT.
THE LETTER SAID ALL SUFFERED
FROM DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
SEXUAL ASSAULT, OR RAPE.
FIVE WOMEN TOOK TO SOCIAL MEDIA
TO SAY THAT THEY DID NOT GIVE
ANY PERMISSION TO USE THEIR
NAME, THREE BINDING LEGAL HELP.
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, THEY WERE
SCARED.
>> ONE OF THE FIRST ESCAPE WITH
HEITKAMP.
>> THIS WAS A MAJOR MISTAKE ON
OUR CAMPAIGN'S PART AND I CAN'T
SAY I'M SORRY ENOUGH.
I AM SO, SO SORRY THAT THIS
HAPPENED.
I'M TRYING TO REACH OUT AND WE
MAKE IT RIGHT.
IT APPEARS THERE WAS A MAJOR
FAILING AS TO A GROUP OF WOMEN
WHO WERE PART OF THE STREAM ON
FACEBOOK.
THAT'S AS MUCH AS WE KNOW ON
>> SENATOR HEIDI HEITKAMP IS
CONSIDERED ONE OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE SENATE DEMOCRATS THIS
CYCLE.
SHE VOTED AGAINST JUSTICE BRETT
KAVANAUGH WHEN MOST OF VOTERS
SUPPORTED IT.
HEITKAMP LOST SUPPORT AMONG
WOMEN AND ANALYSTS SAY PERHAPS
THAT WHO THE OPEN LETTER WORD
NAMED ALEC AIMED AT
AIMED AT.
>> SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN GENERAL
HAS BEEN AN IMPORTANT PART OF
HER PORT
PORTFOLIO.
A QUESTION IF THIS ENDS UP
HURTING HER -- PREVIOUS WORK ON
THAT WILL BOTCH HER.
>> WE INVITED SENATOR HEITKAMP
TO SPEAK WITH US.
HER CAMPAIGN SAID SHE'S IN
NORTH DAKOTA RIGHT NOW AND